Bitte schön.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, geben Sie mir bitte Bescheid.
Wie heißt sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Peter Sommer.
Peter Sommer. Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen bestabieren, Herr Sommer?
Peter ist der Vorname Paula Emil Theodor Emilrich hat.
Okay, dann.
Der Name Sommer ist Siegfried Otto Martha Martha Emilrich hat.
Okay, danke. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Sommer?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin am 1. März 1963 geboren.
1963.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Sommer?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß.
Wie viel wegen Sie zurzeit?
Ungefähr 88 kg.
Danke für die Informationen.
Was für Bescheid haben Sie, Herr Sommer?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich bin heute Morgen auf dem Weg zur Arbeit ausgerutscht.
Es hat geregnet.
Ich bin auf dem Blätter passen.
Ich bin auf meiner rechten Handgelenk gefallen.
Ich habe Schmerzen in meinem rechten Handgelenk.
Schmerzen.
Sie waren bein Pfadet?
Nein, zu Fuß.
Ich bin auf dem Weg zur Arbeit und habe mich verletzt.
Herr Sommer, können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen ganz genau beschreiben?
Sie haben einen Daumen oder eine Post?
Zum Teil stechend und zum Teil auch pochend.
Also habe ich ein zweites Herz.
Ich verstehe.
Wann ist das Unfall passiert?
Das ist heute Morgen passiert.
Sie haben 4 Stunden.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen beurteilen?
Wobei ein sehr leichter, sehr unerträgliches Schmerz entspricht?
Wenn ich mich nicht bewege, dann ist es 5.
Wenn ich mich bewege, dann ist es 8.
Sind die Schmerzen irgendwo ausstrahlen?
Ja, in meiner Hand strahlt es aus.
Und in meinem Unterarm.
Und in der Hand.
Zum Unterarm.
Herr Sommer, sind Sie auch auf dem Kopf hingefallen?
Nein.
Nur Hand.
Nur auch rechte Hand gefallen.
Ich habe mich abstützen können.
Weitere Fälle zu machen, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen genommen?
Ich meine gegen Schmerzen?
Nein.
Ich habe versucht, das nicht zu bewegen.
Ansonsten haben wir nichts gemacht.
Wir sind von der Arbeit her gefahren mit meinen Arbeitskollegen.
Ihr Arbeitskollegen, die Sie hier gebracht haben.
Ja, Sie haben mich hier gebracht.
Während der ausgefallen, haben Sie etwas knistern Geräusch gehört?
Nein.
Das war alles so schnell.
Ich habe nur gemerkt, dass ich auf dem Boden war.
Herr Sommer, unsere Gespräche dauert ungefähr 20 Minuten.
Brauchen Sie jetzt eine Schmerzmittel?
Oder können Sie diese Gespräche durchführen?
Ich bewege mich nicht und dann kann ich das aushalten.
Ich werde Ihre Hand ruhig stellen.
Dann können wir weitergehen.
Danke schön.
Herr Sommer, wann haben Sie letzte Tetanusinfunk aufgefrischt?
Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn die Hand bewegt, kommt mehr Schmerzen.
Fühlen Sie sich auf Kreppeln oder Taubheitsgefühl am Hand und unter Arm?
Nein, ich habe keinen Kreppeln oder Taubheitsgefühl im Hand.
Gibt es Schwellungen?
Ja, mein Handgelenk ist geschwollen und meine Hand ist auch geschwollen.
Sie haben gesagt, Abschuldwunde?
Nein.
Herr Sommer, für den Unfall ist Ihnen Schwindel oder Schwarz für den Augen?
Wie nochmal?
Nein, es war nicht.
Gibt es auch Kraftlosigkeit bei der Hand?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen.
Ich kann meine Finger bewegen, aber ich habe Schmerzen.
War Sie unmächtig?
Nein.
Hatten Sie sehr Störungen oder höchststörungen?
Ja, auch nicht.
Gibt es offene Grunde?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, keine Taubheitsgefühl und Kreppeln?
Nein, ich habe nichts.
Herr Sommer, ich möchte Ihre Allgemeinzustand fragen.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist gut.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Nein, nicht wesentlich.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Haben Sie Probleme mit Durch- oder Anschlapen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit Einschlafen oder Durchschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Gibt es Herzdrahten oder Herzstolpern oder Atemnot, besonders nach dem Unfall?
Nein.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Vorerkrankung, Geschichten, Ställe.
Leiden Sie irgendwer vor Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Diabetes,
Zuckerkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Ja, Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit zehn Jahren ungefähr.
Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Vorerkrankungen? Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Was für Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Das nennt sich ACE-Hemma.
Okay, wissen Sie die Dosierung des Medikaments?
10 mg.
Wie viele Tablette nehmen Sie pro Tag ein?
Nur eine Tablette morgens.
Nehmen Sie etwas Weibedarf, Schmerzmittel oder pflanzliche Medikamente?
Wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, nehme ich im Profäen ein.
Aber ich bin nicht nach Hause gekommen, ich bin direkt hierher gekommen.
Herr Sommer, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, damals, wo ich 15 Jahre alt war, wurde bei mir der Blindarm entfernt.
War diese Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, das war alles normal gelaufen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt?
Stationär behandelt damals, wo ich Blindarm-Operation hatte, war ich stationär?
Ja, aber war ich nicht stationär gewesen?
Okay, sehr gut.
Sind Sie allergisch auf irgendwelche Medikamente oder Substanzstoff?
Ich habe allergie gegenüber der Arbeit.
Ja, ich verstehe das.
Was kann man machen?
Haben Sie eine Lösung gefunden?
Eine Lösung?
Ja, leider.
Wenn Sie finden, bitten Sie mir Bescheid.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten gegen irgendwelche Lebensmittel?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay, jetzt, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre Gewohnheit stellen, Herr Sommer.
Ja, wie viele Zigarette haben Sie pro Tag?
Ja, ich würde sagen, eine Packung, kann man schon sagen.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen viel.
Seit wann haben Sie, Herr Sommer?
35.
35?
Ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich denke, bei Gelegenheit, der ist regelmäßig.
Gelegentlich.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wenn Sie trinken, was für Alkohol trinken Sie?
Ja, hier drücke ich dann.
Ja, okay, danke.
Ja, das ist, die nächste Frage ist, nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich, aber ich muss fragen,
haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, Drogen, nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Sommer, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich wüsste nicht, dass Sie irgendwelche Medikamente nehmen.
Ja, ich denke, das ist ja.
Ja, aber die haben keine Erkrankungen.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Der kleine Sohn ist noch bei uns.
Und der ältere Sohn, der ist außer Haus.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Sommer?
Ich bin Bankangestellter.
In einer Bank im Büro.
So, haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit?
Sie haben Allergie, aber...
Ja, freut mich, ich habe Spaß gemeint.
Nein, ich habe, das war der Arbeit.
Ja, okay, sehr gut.
Die Arbeit hat Stress, ich nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Sommer, wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Ich meine, gegen Kinderheit und gegen Corona,
würden Sie geimpft?
Also gegen die kindliche Erkrankungen usw.
Und die haben geimpft.
Bei Corona wurde ich nicht geimpft.
Ich war zweimal erkrankt, damals keine Erkrankung.
Und danach habe ich mich auch nicht mehr impfen lassen.
Ja, genau, so war meine Erkrankung.
Okay.
Herr Sommer, gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen
in Ihrer Familie, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Bei Alten?
Ja, von dem, was Sie wissen sollten.
Mein Vater hatte einmal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Und Bluthochdruckerkrankungen.
Sind Ihr Vater gesund jetzt?
Mein Vater ist mit 82 Jahren verstorben.
Wegen Herzinfarkt?
Ich gehe davon aus, weiß ich nicht.
Er hatte einen Infarkt gehabt.
Dann ist er verstorben.
Die Pumpe hat nicht mehr gearbeitet.
Wahrscheinlich hat er noch mal einen Infarkt gehabt.
Okay, tut mir leid.
Wie ist Ihre Mutter zuständig?
Meine Mutter ist im Altersheim.
Die ist Dement.
Und Medikamente, die bekommt einiges aber wegen Schlösen
unter Funktionen, wegen Bluthochdruck.
Okay.
Ich weiß das nicht.
Und wegen der neurologischen Medikamente,
wegen Dementen und so weiter,
bekommt sie auch, aber wie die heißen weiß ich nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Geschwister Herr Sommer?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Wie ist Ihr Gesundheitszustand?
Ich meine, dass sie auch ein Bluthochdruck Medikament nimmt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Er weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja, ich bin durch mit dem Gespräch Herr Sommer,
wenn ich etwas falsch verstehe oder vergessen sagen sie mir.
Ich werde jetzt ein kurzer Zusammenpassung machen.
Okay.
Ja, Sie haben heute Morgen auf dem Arbeitsweg,
wegen der Nähe ausgerutscht,
auf dem rechten Hand,
dann...
auf den rechten Hand, gelenk gefallen oder auf den rechten Hand gefallen.
Ja, gefallen.
Und die Schmerzen sind stechend unterpochen.
Die Schmerzintensität im Ruhe 5 von 10,
beim Bewegung, sie haben starke Schmerzen bei 6 von 10.
Und sie haben...
8 von 10.
8 von 10, genau.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den Hand und in den Arm.
Unterarm.
Ja.
Aus. Und sie haben Schwellungern, Kraftlosigkeit
und auch Bewegungseinschränkungen wegen der Schmerzen.
Okay.
Ja, so.
Sie haben keine Rötung und Blauflecken, ja?
Rötung nicht, aber
ich sehe ein bisschen blaue Flecken,
sehe ich so ein bisschen, ja.
Wo ist die Schwellung?
Okay.
So, haben Sie noch Fragen, Herr Sommer?
Ja, wie geht es denn weiter?
Was habe ich denn?
Können Sie mir schon sagen, was ich habe?
Können Sie mir...
Ja, Herr Sommer, ich werde zuerst
Sie körperlich untersuchen
und dann Blut abnehmen.
Dann werde ich eine Röntgen,
Handgelenk und Unterarm
rechts fernlassen.
Okay.
So, haben Sie...
Aber vor Röntgenaufnahme,
ich würde Ihr Hand ruchig stellen,
nicht für nicht mehr Bewegung.
Dann Sie werden nach Röntgenabteilung
gehen.
Okay.
Hab'n Kollegen andere Fragen.
Ich denke es war ein sehr gutes Angriff, Herr Kollege.
Alle Fragen, die hier gestattet.
Ich denke schon, ja.
Hab'n Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich wollte nur fragen,
haben Sie auf Ihre
Ihnen Seite von der Hand gestürzt?
Ja, genau.
Ich bin auf meiner Innenhandseite
aufgekommen, ja.
Okay.
Und waren Sie zuvor zur Arbeit oder nicht im Fahrrad?
Erstmal war ich mit dem Auto zur Arbeit gefahren
von dem Parkplatz zu meiner Arbeitsstelle.
Ich bin zuvor und dabei bin ich ausgerutscht.
Okay.
Ich würde Sie grüben oder
Taubheit gefühlen in Ihre Hand?
Ein.
Okay, danke.
Können wir als erstes gefehlt,
Anfang an, Herr Kollege?
Meinerseits, ja.
Esin Abla.
Ja, ich färschle jetzt.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient gerade gesehen.
Dann ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen möchte.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, deswegen bin ich da.
Bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Es geht um Petersoma.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt.
Am 1. März 1963 geboren.
Er ist 1,86 Meter groß.
Und 88 Kilogramm schwer.
Wie groß ist er?
1,76 Meter.
1,78 Meter.
Okay.
Danke.
Herr Petersoma hat sich heute Morgen
in der Aufnahme bei uns wegen der
Verstündung,
seit vorstunden,
bestehende,
stähende,
pohende
und
starke,
Handgerichte, Handgeläge,
Schmerz sind vorgestellt.
Aus einem Berichtete
der Patient,
die Schmerz,
die Schmerz
in den rechten Hand
und in den Unterarm
ausgestrahlen aus.
Können Sie das noch wieder holen?
Okay.
Die Schmerzinternste hat
in der Hand
in den rechten Hand
ausgestrahlen.
Ausgestrahlen wurde.
Das Schmerzinternste
wurde in der Hand
in den rechten Hand
im Ruhe mit fünf von zehn und beim Bewegung mit acht von zehn auf eine Schmerzkala beurteilt.
Als der weiteren Begleitsyntome erwählte er über Schwellung, Echymose, Ödem, Echymose und auch Kraftlosigkeit
und Bewegungseinstellung.
Auslösersch, wir müssen erst mal sagen nach der Umfalt.
Ich habe nie geübt, oh mein Gott.
Die Schmerzen sind nach dem Unfall aufgetreten.
Wie ist der Unfallmechanismus nochmal?
Er war im Parkplatz und der Patient habe wegen der nasse Boden auf dem rechten, innenflachen Hand aufgefallen.
Die Fragen nach Kopfverletzungen oder Paraisilemmung, vertigo, wurde verneint.
Der Patient hat die letzte Tetonusimpfung vor fünf Jahren.
Hat der weitere Verletzung Kopf nicht?
Aber ist er aufs Knie gefallen oder andere Verletzungszeichen?
Ich habe nicht genau gefragt, aber er hat nicht gefragt.
Nein, der Patient hat keine weiteren Verletzungen.
Nein, Herr Hodja, Sie haben gesagt, ich habe keine weiteren Verletzungen.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass er keine weiteren Verletzungen hat.
Aber erst mal auf jeden Fall, der Unfall, der Arbeitsunfall, in Deutschland ist sehr wichtig.
Nachher hat der Herr Kollegen uns aufklärt, was dabei wichtig ist.
Was hat er gefragt?
Welche Unfall?
Wenn man fragt, würde man sagen, in Deutschland gibt es wie viele Arten von Versicherungen.
Wie viele Versicherungen gibt es in Deutschland?
Ich weiß nur gesetzlich und privat, aber bei der Unfall gibt es auch eine Prozedür für Arbeit.
Wenn der Patient auf dem Arbeitsweg hat, hat es einen Unfall.
Wir müssen die Arzt sagen.
Es gibt die private Versicherung, gesetzliche Versicherung und eine Versicherung, wie nennt man die?
Abkürzung wäre BG.
Es ist egal, ob sie privat sind, gesetzliche Versicherung.
Wenn sie bei der Arbeit oder auf dem Weg zu arbeiten, eine Verletzung haben, ein Unfall leiden,
dann greift die Unfallversicherung.
Die ganzen Kosten, die Therapien, übernimmt nicht ihre Versicherung, sondern die Arbeitsversicherung.
Die Organisation heißt Grußgenossenschaft, Abkürzung BG.
Man nennt dann, das ist ein BG-Fall, der ist begehlich versichert.
Als Arbeitgeber müssen sie sich nicht verstehen. Alle Arbeitnehmer sind begehlich versichert.
Danke.
Wir haben gesagt, es ist eine besondere Prozedur, wie man eine Aufnahme von einem Arbeitsunfall macht.
Da geht es auf Detail, um wie viel Uhr ist es passiert, wann beginnen Sie die Arbeit, wann hören Sie auf, was für eine BG.
Es gibt in Deutschland 16 BGs, BG für Arbeit, Gesundheit, Chemie usw.
Es gibt eine BG für die BG, die sind unterteilt in den Bundesland.
Es ist eine bestimmte Prozedur, die eingeladen wird.
Das war es.
Danke schön.
Es war manchmal eine Schmerzmittel als Ibuprofen.
Es wurde beim Patienten eine Appendeptomie mit 15 durchgeführt.
Es war komplikationlos. Es sind keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er ist 20 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 35 Jahren. Er trinkt BIA-Gelegenkisch.
Sie müssen 35 Zagen rauchen.
Er ist ein Erzeuger.
Bank anbestellte als Beruf und sein im Status vollständig, er habe zwei Mal Corona Infektion
gehabt. Genesung, würde ich sagen. Er hatte zweimal die Corona-Erkrankung durchgemacht.
Und dadurch hatte er einen Genesenen Status.
In der Familienanalyse berichtete er, dass sein Vater hatte,
Herz-Myocard-Impfarkt arterielle Hypertonie hatte.
Er ist wahrscheinlich eine Herz-Myocard-Impfarkt mit zwei und 80 Jahre verstorben.
Seine Mutter hatte eine Hypotheorie und eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Er hatte eine Schwester und sie leidete an die arterielle Hypertonie.
Die Analyse-Angaben-Boten am Ehesten auf eine Handgelegene Traktur hin.
Die Diagnostik kommt eine Bandverletzung oder?
Eine Bandverletzung oder eine Bandverletzung?
Eine Bandverletzung.
Eine Bandlesion.
Eine Handgelenks-Distortion.
Eine Handgelenks-Fraktur.
Was ist die meist Handgelenks-Fraktur?
Die Stahlradius-Fraktur.
Ich habe eine Stahlradius-Fraktur gedacht wegen der Traumemökismus.
Es ist eine Extension-Fraktur.
Was könnte noch für eine Fraktur sein?
Die andere könnte auch eine isolierte Fraktur sein.
Was ist die letzte Fraktur?
Die letzte?
Die andere könnte auch eine distale Fraktur sein.
Was ist die letzte Fraktur?
Die nächste Fraktur ist eine Handgelenks-Wurzel-Fraktur.
Was ist das nicht gleich?
Die Handgelenks-Fraktur sind auch die Handwurzelknochen.
Was ist die letzte Fraktur?
Die andere Seite ist Mittelhandknochen.
Die nächste Fraktur ist die Handgelenks-Fraktur.
Welche Therapie?
Ich werde Röntgenaufnahme, Reiz, Handgelenk und Unterarm in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Je nach Ergebnisse werde ich entweder konservativ oder operativ behandeln.
Was wäre zum Beispiel, wenn ihr eine nicht wesentliche oder leicht distalerte Rathus-Extensionsfraktur habt?
Ich werde konservativ nicht distalert werden.
Ich werde eine Dorsale-Gibb-Schiene anlegen.
Warum gibt es keine Zirkulären?
Es gibt Schwellunggern.
Es gibt Zunahme der Schwellung.
Es gibt Zirkulärgipf-Verband.
Wie lange würde es eine Gipf-Schiene dranbleiben?
Es gibt 4 bis 6 Wochen.
Schwellung verschwunden.
Wir sollten auch Physiotherapie nach der Heilung.
Was würden Sie regelmäßig kontrollieren?
Wir achten auf die Schwellung.
Wie würden Sie das grob sagen?
Ich werde durchsputungstörungen und durchsputungstörungen.
Sie haben eine Fraktur?
Sie wollen wissen, ob es in 1 oder 2 Wochen immer noch dieselbe Stellung gibt.
Es ist eine diskluzierte Radius-Extensionsfraktur mit Gelegbeteiligung.
Was empfehlen Sie?
Ich werde eine Operation empfehlen.
Ich werde die Komplikationen erklären.
Ich werde die Operation empfehlen.
Nachdem er über Risiken und Problematik ausführlich in seiner Zukunft kommt,
würden Sie nur den Unterricht gegen Ärzte in Rat.
Ich werde die Operation empfehlen.
Ich wollte, dass Sie auf Risiken aufklären.